[Music]
cool hello everybody
wow I'm loud welcome to building massive
online worlds with spacial OS and Google
cloud platform my name is Mark Mandell
I'm developer advocate for Google cloud
and I'm a Rob whitehead I'm CTO and
proble cool so before we get started
let's get a sense of the room hands up
the people here who are a game
developers what I expected hobbyist game
developers
all right cool people who are into like
simulations yeah simple Venn diagram
cool people who are just interested
because this seemed cool that's fine too
well awesome all right fantastic oh I
tell you what since we're here Rob thank
you so much for joining us I really
appreciate you taking the time to talk
with us about spatial OS so that
everyone has a sense of what it is we're
talking about today why don't you give
us like the general overview of what
improbable is and what spatial OS is all
about yeah for sure
so we're improbable for a group about
150 of us disputed across London San
Francisco and our goal is really kind of
building a platform to let you kind of
go beyond the traditional limits of a
single server and to build massive
living simulated online worlds
either using them apply to kind of video
games so you can see in this video or
using them to like understand the real
world with like simulating a city or an
ecology so what's going on here this is
an example of a game bill with one our
partners called walls adrift and this is
a massively living online world which is
running in the cloud and is powered by
not just a single dedicated server but
like traditional games are used to you
but actually hundreds of game engines
cooperating and overlapping together to
simulate a world much bigger than any
single one could ever deal with and
connecting into our thousands of
different players all across the world
again like sort of more than a single
dedicated server or VM could ever deal
with jamming at a YouTube is always fun
awesome so you may be wondering like why
we're talking about improbable and
special OS at Google cloud next so the
answer that really is is that Google
cloud platform is always looking for new
partners that share a desire for
innovate
and especially innovation in the game
space we really want to partner with
people who want to let people build oh
god I'm gonna say it really what's next
in in the gaming world and really just
across the board as well to that end
we're actually really happy to be
partnering with him probable to help
them develop the gate and the spatial OS
games Innovation Program Rob can you
tell us about how that goes yeah for
sure so when we kind of went out into
the game's community we found there were
these fantastic ideas people had about
leveraging this amount of Clowry source
to build like the next generation of
like simulated living game worlds and we
found people were apprehensive in terms
of the cloud costs that they might incur
in terms of their development on R&D and
Google and probably got together and the
innovation program allows us to offer
like free development costs in terms of
cloud for people from starting
developments all the way through to
commercial launch so the idea is to kind
of like sort of a lot of people say like
Anna let loose in experiment and try and
do some crazy things without being
worried about kind of the the cost
they're going to incur to do that so
that sounds pretty cool why don't we
check out how that actually works
awesome so I'm gonna kind of talk on a
high level about our platform as a
service and its kind of core
architecture and how you think about it
and what the abstraction is on top of
traditional servers then I'm going to
give you an actual live demo on my
laptop of it running on my local machine
and then we're going to dive into some
code snippets and kind of show you under
the hood for those of you who've coated
with unity3d you might find some of the
API is quite familiar who's actually use
unity out of curiosity great so for
those you who kind of may be aware
traditionally when you have online game
worlds they'll have a dedicated server
and that's a process running inside
either a dedicated server somewhere on a
metal hardware or on a VM in the cloud
and all the clients within that world
connect into that single server and this
works pretty well when you have a small
amount of concurrent players or if you
have a small amount of simulation going
on if your walls not that complex but
you encounter issues when you want to
have thousands or tens of thousands of
people in the same environment and you
want to have worlds that are truly
living if you want to have a game world
which has you know millions of trees
which actually grow and like a real
ecology in a real economy you kind of
start to hit the fundamental limits of a
single machine no matter how many cores
you again
so the whole idea of spacial OS is it's
a it's a distributed operating system so
that is to say it's a abstraction on top
of lots of computers lots of VM so they
should treat of it as a one big one big
machine in some senses and the the core
idea is rather than having a single
dedicated server which you'd only have
you know unity compiled out as a Linux
dedicated server or in real dedicated
server spatial OS actually orchestrates
a swarm of dedicated servers potentially
hundreds of thousands of them all with
overlapping areas of interest all kind
of combined together to simulate a
massive game world cool so basically
kind of what you're telling me is it's
kind of like a traditional platform
as-a-service
but just for a massive online persistent
worlds yeah exactly and you think about
and the whole reason we call a spatial
OS is you think about this big cluster
of machines as a three dimensional space
which contains your computation Watson
so as a developer then what is the
lifecycle look like how am i building my
stuff yeah for sure service again a
traditional kind of platform is a
service style you see you have a set of
CLI tools and web tools you download
from spatial Escom you can do this today
you could do it right now you should
listen to us instead though and once you
downloaded those tools we have
integrations into unity into unreal and
we also have base language integrations
so you can write code it works in this
manner in c-sharp C++ Java and then you
used to use some CLI commands to package
up your application push it into the
spatial s platform and then like sort of
on our side we're going to be using as
much computation as it's necessary to
simulate your world so these are the
kind of cool words which you use when
you're thinking about building something
with spatial of us and some of you might
find some of these words familiar
because there are very much inspired by
game engine architecture and some of you
might find that you know like work is a
new word we've kind of invented but it's
actually a broadening and an abstraction
from things you're probably familiar
with so in spatial OS the core idea of
the world is it contains entities it
contains things so in a video game like
you saw worlds adrift before each player
is an entity the rocks on the floor and
entity the trees which can be chopped
down or entities and even the ships are
actually composed of hundreds of
entities so they really represent the
domain of your application you can
imagine if you're using spatial as to
simulate a city you might use entities
to
Road segments buildings traffic signals
all kinds of different things then you
have components so this is like a
traditional structure of game engine
architectures and what I'll let you do
is rather than having like sort of
really big monolithic ideas of objects
unless you compose them out of pieces
which make a lot easier to reason about
so rather than thinking about a monster
you think about something which is a
rigid body which means it can move in
physical space it has a Collider which
is means it can bump into other things
and it has a navigation component which
defines the idea of a Hamming like a
destination to go to and some waypoints
along the way so the interesting thing
here is workers workers are I guess you
can think of them as like micro-services
little pieces of code which either are
connecting in over the internet like a
game engine clients all running within
spatialize itself which are
authoritative over parts of entities as
in their components so you can imagine
taking a physics engine like physics and
having that simulates all the rigidbody
components of the entities in the world
but the the magic which is going on here
is maybe physics can only simulate ten
thousand rigid bodies and your game
world has 1 million rigid bodies while
space rocks can do is actually span up
100 instances of that process
distributed across the cluster and have
them all cooperate together and
spatialize is handling all the
synchronization and all the
orchestration that's going on for you so
to kind of like sort of bring it back
into a concrete example based upon the
video you saw with worlds adrift from
from that side within one their worlds
the worlds are about 50 by 50 kilometers
and you're looking at kind of over half
a million fully physically simulated
objects inside that game so creatures
players panels of a ship can fall off
and fall onto the ground and be
completely persisted each one of those
islands you saw I kind of build out of
like voxels through like a
user-generated content tool and there's
Islands themselves ever have about 3,000
entities from even like an egg on the
ground or a tree that they're all
they're all entities and every single
one is nc's is fully persistent so the
whole idea of spatial OS maintains the
data representation of the world
completely distinct from any one of
these processes or clients connected in
so if you drop a like a sword in a bush
and you kind of come away you should
come back to it and years later should
still be there and this is because you
can think about spatial versus an
in-memory database which is maintaining
all those
and in terms of examples of components
inside of walls adrift some of them are
kind of very familiar you might find it
for your gamedev but within world if
they're actually real like a real
ecology of creatures and they even have
components about pregnancy and how
hungry they are and it's yeah it's
really crazy how much depth you can go
into to to define those entities and
then in terms of workers you have you
know your workers running in in the
cloud so for water if they have 200
unity linux instances or cooperating
together to simulator space and they
have about 1,000 unity clients which are
players connecting in all across the
world to simulate the world so again
something massive and far bigger than
any single game engine could deal with
awesome that sounds really great so why
don't we cut to the demo and you can
actually show us this thing in action
yeah for sure
so this is where it gets really fun and
so it's worth saying you know spatial OS
is a platform as a service it's a it's a
tool which lets you run large scale
simulations in the cloud but often for
local development is convenient to you
have a local spatial OS and specialists
can use you know a single machine or can
use a thousand machines so we can see
here is it using just a single machine
on my my local machine and we're gonna
be using a tutorial which is available
online right now for unity integration
so let's go ahead and start it so yeah
the idea of this like sort of demo is
it's like a little diorama or a special
OS it's going to show you the core
concepts at work and like sort of
although we can scale to maybe hundreds
of thousands times larger than you'll
see here it already kind of leave you
with a feeling of kind of what's going
on under the hood
it's working good so what I'm gonna run
here on my local machine is a
traditional built out unity client and
I'm gonna be running around as a awesome
little wizard which is gonna be able to
go around and set things on fire which
is gonna be really really cute there we
go so you know it's is pretty much like
sort of a any kind of like sort of a
game you might be familiar with and this
little guy I can go around I can like
see things going on
I can set things on fire and I can also
set little people on fire which is not
very nice to do but I can and is it's
definitely gonna happen I'm sorry I
missed but then you'll see it's like
just like any other game but already
kind of what you should see here is the
game world is actually much bigger than
what's inside this single unity client
the world's actually contains its tens
of thousands of trees and there's
actually another base very similar to
this on the on the other side of the
world but what's happening is as I move
around you kind of will notice it but
the the subset of the world I'm
interested in is being streamed in I
suppose Louis and this clients the
simulation of those little dudes running
around isn't actually being done on my
client it's being done on a built out
dedicated Unity server running on my
machine which is connected in two
spatial OS and this client rather than
being connected into the dedicated
server is connected into spatial OS and
spatial ice is managing the interest of
the world I go around okay I'm gonna
have to get really accurate this now
come on nest so right we can come back
to later when there's more people so the
first thing which I want to show you is
that's kind of what the game client sees
the world as I want to show you what
spatial s sees the game orders so this
is the entire space again it's a
relatively small simulation it's about
ten thousand entities and already you
can see that we're actually running not
just a single dedicated server but
they're actually two dedicated servers
running and overlapping together to
simulate a world kind of much bigger
than a single one could deal with for an
extended period of time and if you zoom
in here you can actually see this
overlap area and well this is showing
you as well is the canonical data
representation of the entities inside
the world so although unity sees them
when you log in as a client
these really high fidelity evil
graphical assets you can see here I can
go ahead and click and this is this is a
tree and if I go ahead and like sort of
click on it it can actually show me the
components of of the entity and this is
really important having this agnostic
representation of the world because we
don't care whether the game engines and
and dedicated servers have been written
in C sharp or C++ or Java or whether
you've used unity or unreal this is this
kind of canonical agnostic
representation of everything going on so
we can already start to do some fun
things which are really scary to do on
stage but actually work out pretty well
so one things which happens when you're
running not two but two hundred or two
thousand game engines is in the cloud
sometimes they'll crash you know code it
you know has a mean time to failure so
if I go ahead and pull the power cord
out of one of these workers what's gonna
happen is you've actually zoom in you'll
find the top right hand side of the
world is actually still being simulated
but the bottom left is actually paused
there's almost a good glitch in the
matrix but if i zoom out you'll find
that spatial has detected the failure
and it's actually started up a new
worker to replace it in this top left
hand corner and what we're showing off
here is our dynamic load balancing
algorithms whereby two workers can
actually change the spatial area of
interest in real time to deal with
fluctuations of load so if you have like
a really big epicenter of like sort of
comic going on you can actually have a
worker move the area space and shrink in
and kind of focus on what's happening
cool let's go back and see this more
more NPCs to have fun with yeah that's a
lot more oh no no that's a really bad
idea that's right one of my friends put
me out clearly nicer than me the other
thing to show you here as well is if i
zoom in here this is actually showing
the the subset of the world which the
client is actually connected into and
the little blue dots if you can see it
is my player and as I move around the
world space show us is understanding the
the subset of the world I'm interested
in and it's going to go ahead and move
like a window of interest within my
world and streaming it in so this is
again demonstrating you can have game
worlds
substantially larger than any single
instance of unity could ever deal with
the thin side of memory and as you move
around it's actually extreme again just
a subset of the world you're interested
in and it's gonna be keeping you up
today that cool that pretty much
concludes the demo run it dive into some
code examples we can switch back please
thank you all right that sounds really
great um so yeah let's have a look at
some code examples and you can kind of
talk us through how the actual coding
aspect of special west works yeah for
sure
so the first thing to talk about here is
the the spatial s schema language so I
talked before about spatial OS having a
kind of canonical data representation of
the world which is completely
distinctive any language or any kind of
clients or any kind of server like micro
service or kind of game engine connected
in and this is how you define that so
this lets you define the abstract idea
of a entity without any understanding of
its implementation which gives you the
flexibility to use whatever tools you
want so this example here I'm going to
show you the implementation of
flammability within within unity and it
starts off by defining this canonical
abstract idea of a component so I'm
going to call it flammability and I'm
gonna give it the idea of a property
being is on fire because obviously I
want to have some state for is this
thing like sort of you know not on fire
or on fire and the thing we're gonna add
as well is a command so commands or
spatial OS is RPC mechanism which lets
two workers communicate with each other
and I'm gonna define a command here
called ignite which is if I'm something
which is on fire and I'm something which
is not on fire I can send an ignite
command to the thing which is not on
fire and make it ignite and the awesome
thing spatial is doing for you is it's
gonna automatically routes that RPC to
whatever worker is authoritative on that
components at any point in time so you
had this kind of really nice
transparency going on and if it turns
out you're the actual worker who's
authoritative for that command it's
going to short-circuit it and you're
gonna get like sort of a efficiency
already built in so this first part of
the example is going to be about our
implementation of the Unity server code
so this is the code running inside
of the workers you saw before the two
the two overlapping processes and those
you who are kind of who's like who's
written like sort of unity code before
in c-sharp dances yeah so you'll see
something here which is quite familiar
which is a unity mana behavior and the
thing which is cool and the thing which
is new is that first line where you see
require flammability writer so spatial
lysis SDK has a really powerful code
generation tool built-in which takes
those components you defined in the
spatial schema language and generates
idiomatic api's in whatever kind of
platform you're writing clients or
dedicated server processors for so in
unity it's going to go ahead and write
these these classes which demonstrate
the ability to read them right from a
particular component in unreal will
actually generate you actor components
and you'll be able to use the blueprint
visual scripting tool to actually wire
up and do things that way or if you're
kind of writing like a small c-sharp
microservice or something in java you're
gonna get again some like sort of
relatively straightforward api's which
you can use to hook into the different
parts of density and the first thing i'm
going to do in this sample here is add
in a implementation for ignite this is
saying when someone tells me to ignite
here is implementation or the callback
to call so this is the next bit of code
so those of you kind of unfamiliar with
with unity it has a an idea of a trigger
so this is a collider which you can
actually walk through but when you walk
through and into it it's gonna fire an
event to tell you that somebody's kind
of gone into it and this is a really
good tool inside of unity for dealing
with them objects kind of moving within
proximity of each other and you're
getting alerted of that so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna use the the
trigger system of unity and kind of tie
that into spatial OS so that when
somebody moves into my trigger region
I'm gonna check out am I on fire and if
I'm on fire I'm gonna send the thing
that moved into my trigger region a
command and the command is either going
to what specialist are gonna do for you
is it's going to work out is that is it
entity on my on my worker locally am i
authoritative for it then I'm gonna
invoke the command locally if it's not
it's gonna send it through spatial wesen
it's gonna work out whatever worker
across the cluster is authoritative for
that entity
that's gonna invoke that RPC and it's
worth noting here I didn't write any
kind of sterilization code I didn't
write any data synchronization code it's
all handled for you you just kind of
invoked this method and we're gonna
choose the most appropriate thing to do
and the the final thing to see here is
the light handler so this is when my me
myself I've received an RPC from
somebody just to make myself ignite and
this is the implementation I've defined
in unity code on the dedicated server to
handler and what you can see I'm gonna
be doing here is checking am I am I not
on fire if I'm not on fire I'm going to
send a new update which sets me on fire
so when you do that dot send
what's going to happen is that dedicated
server worker is going to send a message
into spatial s all for you and space
Russ is gonna work out exactly what
other workers need to know about that
property update so maybe there are 1,000
clients or watching this tree like
really excited for it to spontaneously
set on fire and when that pyromaniac
cetera and when when it ignites speacial
s is going to do that kind of
distributed synchronization across all
those different workers and those
workers might be running on different
machines across the world they might be
running on different machines in the
cloud we handle that kind of
synchronization effort and you didn't
write any network synchronization code
you didn't write any kind of like sort
of like you know any kind of reliable
UDP stuff going on were using like sort
of best-in-class like sort of transport
stuff to go ahead and do that for you
and then this is the kind of the the fun
bit I guess which is although spatial
that's one of the core ideas or is that
it maintains for every components of
every entity there is only ever one
worker which is authoritative for it
which really helps in terms of race
conditions and that kind of thing there
may be arbitrarily many workers
interested in reading a component so you
could imagine there being thousands of
clients again like interested in the in
that tree and what you use in this case
is rather than injecting in a
flammability reader/writer interface you
inject in a reader and this reader is
going to give you callbacks for being
told when the the component data of that
entity has updated so what I've done
here is when I enable I'm adding
on a visualization update so I'm gonna
make a callback for when this objects
either becomes on fire or ceases to be
on fire and then in classic unity
fashion I've got a particle system which
I've kind of like sort of got wired up
here you can imagine it being inside of
a game object inside of unity and based
upon the abstract idea of spatial OS
it's fun ability being on fire or not on
fire I'm gonna go ahead and actually
that with them a particle system being
enabled and disabled and this is a
really nice decoupling you might be
familiar with it if you're kind of from
the webdev world of your mortal being
decoupled from your view and this is
really nice because you know this flames
visualizer is the one which is used on
trees you can imagine the the one which
is being used for NPCs with them kind of
flailing around their hands in in in a
very cute and terrifying fashion is is
is it is a different piece of code so
lets you kind of really nicely
compartmentalize the implementation of
the components and from the
visualizations which might take place on
different kinds of client and you could
even imagine the visualizer code on a
mobile device which is connected into
the same world might use a like you know
a sprite rather than a full-on particle
system cool so I mean you showed us a
bunch of unity code just so we're all
aware as well like this works on unity
this works on a real human our custom
engines yeah exactly so as I said before
the the api's we generate we have really
really deep integrations into unreal and
unity which lets you have these really
nice idiomatic interfaces but if you
want to write just a micro service to do
something like say a stop finding for
your for your kind of empties moving
around you can use our kind of lower
layer language worker integration
instead awesome
alright so we are here at cloud next
obviously so not only is it great to
hear from you and about special OS and
how it works but i'm guessing there's
some people in the audience who may want
to hear about like while you're with us
why are you with google platform
excellent so i know you use a few
different products of ours on google
cloud platform
the first of which is compute engine so
i know from my perspective developer
advocacy quite often i speak a lot about
like the cool new shiny stuff or the
stuff that automatically scales like app
engine or something like communities but
you use a lot of virtual machines i
compute engine so you're not familiar
like compute engine those are the
virtual machines that run on Google
cloud platform you spin them up swimming
down they're very traditional and what
they use can you talk about your
experience using those yeah for sure
so for clarity spatial OS itself as a
platform as a service which means you
have an account with with the spatial OS
and you use those CLI tools to kind of
deploy to the cloud but under the hood
we're actually using Google Cloud sexual
like sort of infrastructure to be able
to run and scale your simulation and
when we were choosing like cloud
providers to run on and we found that
Google cloud platform had some favorable
characteristics for certain kinds of
things we use so when I talked about
worlds adrift running before it's
actually running about 500 cores worth
of worth of compute I cross about 50
machines and very actually good off you
know VMs running on Google compute
engine and when you type in spatial
deploy which is the command to actually
go and like start your simulation what
we're doing another hood is actually
starting Google GCE VMs to actually be
running the the power and the kind of
the workhorse of all the simulation
going on here
so the thing we actually found with
compute engine which made it really good
for our use cases is we want small teams
to be able to iterate really fast and we
want you to kind of come up with a
really crazy idea for a multiplayer game
write some code and then just run it in
the cloud and then share a link with
your friends and then you can all log in
and play it and the provisioning time of
a VM which is the time you say hey I
want a VM - here is your VM is a really
important part of that iteration process
especially when you're working with
teams so the awesome thing about GCE for
us is the provisioning times which we
found to be really quite favorable
compared to you other cloud providers
and what that means for you as a
specialized developer is you got that
faster turnaround time and you can
experiment quicker cool and I think
you're also looking at custom VMs so if
you're not actually familiar with those
either Google cloud platform gives you
the ability to create VMs with exactly
the same number of CPUs exactly the
number of CPUs and memory that it is you
want to use and that works very well for
you as well yeah this is something we're
kind of investigating right now when you
imagine running a game engine like unity
in the cloud you want to make sure that
you don't have any memory you're not
really using or any CPU you're not using
and from that side if we can better pack
unity instances on t vm s it's cheaper
for us to run which means we can make it
cheaper
for you to use and that's a very
powerful tool there especially because
game engines are quite weird beasts when
they run the cloud and they have quite
quite strange kind of resourcing
requirements sometimes awesome so when
you and I got together instead of
talking about this we also started
talking about the Google cloud platform
network which I don't know if we
necessarily talk about as much but I
think he's really cool and interesting
so firm obviously or possibly not
obviously we run on the same
infrastructure same apps in E like Gmail
and all the other Google services and as
you may have heard from all the stuff
that's been going on around spanner the
network that runs Google cloud platform
enables us to do some really cool stuff
and is exceptionally fast I think you've
had a pretty pretty similar experience
running your stuff on Google cloud
platforms Network yeah indeed so the
first thing about real time multiplayer
games which is quite different than
traditional
applications is rather than kind of
using TCP as in line transport a lot of
more based around UDP and that's because
when you're receiving a firehose of say
60 updates a second of a player position
if you drop some of those packets TCP is
going to go ahead and go hold on hold on
and you know you can I get these delays
whilst it tries to reassemble and give
you a reliable stream but with the
player position I'd rather just get the
next position if I miss one and UDP is a
natural kind of like choice of transport
for that and it's basically
best-in-class for the industry and what
ends up happening is people end up
there's really popular open source
libraries like rack net which are
abstractions on top of UDP to give you
semi reliability so you can imagine in a
position of day of one of those panels
falling down and wells adrift is
actually being sent I'm reliably with
UDP the something like like one of those
RPC is to ignite is actually sent
reliably so rack net lets you kind of
like have you can turn the dial from
like sort of fully and reliable to fully
reliable and in terms of how that
applies to you like sort of Google
earnest networking cloud providers I
guess traditionally we're ready both
around scaling web services so you know
I've got some sass tea you know Facebook
for dogs or something and I want to kind
of scale out the the front-end web
servers which are hosting that and when
we went ahead and tried to start using
cloud providers for UDP especially like
fire hoses or VP packets you'd find
there are limitations in terms of the
especially with small UDP packets
many of them you can send per second on
a single uh VM and when we were kind of
profiling around we found you know
Google's networking had a really solid
kind of performance in terms of being
able to I think sent like hundreds of
thousands of packets a second from from
from a single VM and that really
translates into you we got to have
richer bigger more interesting worlds
and have more players packed onto a
single server which is an important part
of having you know very dense combine
really interesting gameplay and yes
we're saying as well that we use like
sort of clusters all over the world so
we have the clusters in the u.s. we have
clusters in Europe we have clusters in
Asia are never linked on Google compute
machines but people are connecting over
the internet using Google's networking
infrastructure to connect into those
specialized deployments you know it's
something we don't probably talk about
that often necessarily in the game space
is storage right so you also do really
neat stuff with Google Cloud storage so
again if you're not familiar with Google
Cloud storage this is the place for you
to store binary files on our system the
nice thing about it is that we have nice
things like edge caching you can store a
petabytes of data on it it'll do
regional and multi-regional replication
for you out of the box so it comes with
a lot of good stuff but I've seen you
use it in kind of interactive ways it
kind of works really nicely yeah it's
really cool
so you saw before what spatial OS sees a
game world as it sees it as just dots in
in a kind of arbitrary three-dimensional
space but when you kind of walking in in
your game and you encounter an object
maybe it's an object you actually
haven't seen before
spatial OS doesn't actually contain in
its in-memory representation the actual
mesh data and like sort of the the
assets which represent the object all it
contains is a pointer into Google Cloud
storage which contains the actual unity
asset bundle you download and this makes
a ton of sense because spatial rest is
optimized for high amounts sort of kind
of data throughput it's optimized for
you know components updating maybe you
know hundreds of times a second
we don't be storing kind of blobs of
megabytes or gigabytes of data in that
thing as well does it make sense so we
kind of have this like this this tandem
thing which makes sense so when you kind
of fly around your ship and walls of
drift and you see an island you haven't
seen before what's gonna happen is a
spatial s will say oh the island is
called island for 7:09
then using spatial SS api's you can
actually hook into our kind of wheel or
assembly service which is gonna fetch to
you from Google Cloud Storage the
appropriate Island for you to download
as an asset bundle stream in in real
time using your game engine and spawn
into the game and when were you kind of
choosing GCS traditionally you'd kind of
think that you need to use a CDN for
this kind of thing but we actually got
profiled that GCS against like sort of
conventional CDN providers and we found
it was comparable and we were using this
anyway for like sort of how we store a
lot of a lot of things within spatial so
yeah made total sense for us fantastic
so you're using a bunch of program
brochure products from Google cloud
platform which is great but you're also
using some open source stuff as well
yeah actually using one of my favorite
open source projects G RPC so G RPC is a
high-performance open source universal
remote procedure call framework yeah it
came out of stubby so it came out of
historically our internal remote
procedure call framework called stubby
it's really really cool works really
really fast it does streaming data
really really well has been a huge thing
around how we talk about micro services
at Google and Google Cloud can you talk
about how you've been using and I think
it's really interesting for games
yeah for sure so you can imagine with
gains bandwidth is absolutely key and
performance is absolutely key you don't
it'll be fire hosing around like JSON
blobs which represent entity position
when you're sending hundreds of them a
second per entity and you might have a
thousand entities in your scene and also
like sort of when you're running like
sort of like improbable we have a team
of like around like sort of 100
engineers you we have a constellation of
different micro services that make up
spatial OS so besides the actual runtime
which is this kind of in memory spatial
simulation representation we have micro
services for things like accounts
billing storing deployment snapshots of
your world storing like the the binary
assets you kind of downloads like your
trees etc and we reached a point where
we were using kinda like a restful a
restful interface for all those things
but you start to have a lot of issues
arise because you don't have a typed
representation of that interface and you
don't have teams like stepping on each
other's toes and you have to rely on
like large amounts of unit testing and
integration testing to make sure your
your software works but under the hood
for us we used you up
see for all of our micro service
architecture and actually when with a
spatial if you type in spatial deploy
that's actually using geo RPC calls to
talk to our platform to kick on a kick
off that deployment and another thing we
actually have in the pipeline as well is
that inspector you saw that kind of
WebGL accelerated entity view when you
kind of move it around it actually sets
up a stream inquiry for a subset of the
world to be streamed down into the
browser and again geo RPC looks like a
very powerful candidate to kind of help
accelerate that as well and it's kind of
based on HTTP two as well so it's it's
really nice for kind of lots and lots of
like sort of request responses very
quickly and also for streaming responses
fantastic suite
so you've shown us some really amazing
stuff super excited about special OS I
think it's really exciting tech can you
tell us about what plans you have for
the future what can we see what's coming
up down the pipeline yes so there's kind
of two different angles to talk about so
the the natural first thing is about
scale and performance we really want to
be this platform where you can have game
worlds or even simulations of the living
world which are kind of reality scale
and by that we mean millions of
concurrent players in the same
environment with high fidelity physics
maybe even in VR and billions of
simulated entities which have rich AI
they're fully physical and they're fully
persistent and all of our dev teams are
special especially our indie side of
focused on trying to push the
capabilities of spatial OS further and
further and that really comes down to
you how many clients you can have in
that world and also how many servers can
participate in this single uncharted
seamless spatial computation and I'm
really excited to kind of see the
direction we go in the next couple of
years that we kind of want to build a
matrix that's poisoning me it's a story
for another time but that's kind of you
can imagine the foundations of it based
upon that and then the other side is now
we're kind of you know friends at Google
is looking at the constellation of tools
and services they have and how people
could easily tie them in working with
spatial OS to do some awesome new things
so you can imagine a a game world which
is like you know a successor to a
Pokemon go geo game where you're using
Google Maps data and streaming that in
and using Google Maps objects to
represent spatial s entities that could
be really exciting or on are kind of
non-gaming
side doing city simulations that are
actually based upon google maps is like
sort of traffic information and building
information be ready exciting we have
some like sort of interesting angles
looking at what kind of youtube and how
streaming plays a part in real living
worlds and i think there's some exciting
stuff we can talk about soon on that and
then kind of again another kind of sis
gonna ask kind of thing to think about
is integrating in technologies like
tensor flow into spatial so i took
before about the workers that connect
into spatial s can be completely
arbitrary so i had i am a hackathon team
a few weeks ago and they actually
integrated a c++ tensorflow worker
running an interactive mode into spatial
OS and we're doing reinforcement
learning of these little entities kind
of moving around and eating things
inside a spatial and they were kind of
sharing the same brain so as you had
multiple entities in the same world they
were actually combining together
learning information and i think the
idea of spatial wes is a almost like a
kindergarten or a sandbox for a eyes to
learn about like physical systems and
learn how to interact these are really
exciting proposal as well fantastic
alright well we're gonna have plenty of
time for questions which is great first
of all rob thank you so much for joining
us on stage but before we go do you have
any final thoughts or like the one thing
that people will need to remember about
spatial OS before they end up leaving
the room yeah it's not crazy magic
technology you can literally go to
spatial Escom right now you can download
the sdk you can play around with it in
terms of where you can use it for you
can use it with unity and you can like
sort of be running things in the cloud
you can be using unreal and yeah you can
also be using like whatever language or
whatever tools you're familiar with
they're very easy to integrate into
spatial s's representation of the world
and in terms of the two things we want
to let people do a spatial on the gaming
side one is teams like no matter how big
or small they are being able to do
fundamentally new kinds of things in the
game industry so game worlds which are
like truly persistent have millions of
living objects inside of them tens of
thousands of people inside of them
simultaneously we want to make that
possible and also because spatial ice is
a platform as a service we want to take
small teams teams like Bossa who don't
really have an infrastructure team they
don't have network programmers they
don't have all the people you
traditionally expect you need to build
persistent walls they're going ahead
they're picking up spatial OS and it's
unity integration
they're doing things which really they'd
find like fundamentally impossible or
they need to hire beyond their means to
make it possible so it's about everybody
being on skew fundamentally new kinds of
things and small teams being able to go
further without any specialist
techniques and tools building the next
games building yeah I just like it's
terrible I know
excellent so if people want to learn
more about spatial OS spatial OS comm
like you mentioned the github has the
github github has the hello world sample
they're available for you to do if
people want to reach out to you on
Twitter or email yeah yep go ahead and
say like the the forms of spatial OS are
really active and definitely worth
checking out and the the demo I ran
through today is actually the exact demo
you use when you sign up for spatial OS
you get access and you kind of go
through your first kind of hello well
tutorial you'll be running through
exactly what we ran through here but the
next step is deploying onto the cloud
and then sharing with people excellent
well so if anyone has any questions
there is a microphone standing right
there so if you could come up to it and
if you could ask your question so I can
get on the recording that would be great
but otherwise thank you very much - Rob
thank you very much for your time do we
have any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
you